las calles de Puerto Príncipe los
residentes se ven obligados a buscar
agua potable en contenedores mientras la
preocupación crece porque Haití se
enfrenta a un nuevo rebrote de cólera
después de más de tres años sin ningún
caso activo en los últimos días se han
reportado varias muertes por la
enfermedad
una muerte ocurrió en el transcurso de
hoy Lamentablemente fue una persona que
falleció en la comunidad esto es un
problema cuando hay personas que tienen
diarrea vómitos y no tienen como asistir
a un centro de salud donde podrían
sobrevivir
las autoridades instan a la población a
la mayor prudencia posible y han pedido
adoptar estrictas medidas de higiene
para evitar la transmisión pero el país
está en medio de una crisis la subida de
los precios de los combustibles está
causando un inmenso enfado lo que ha
generado violentas protestas en las que
se han instalado barricadas en las
calles estas impiden el paso de equipos
médicos así como de camiones para
recoger la basura en el contexto actual
de malestar social e inseguridad es
indispensable que estos equipos tengan
garantizado el acceso seguro a las áreas
de riesgo incluso donde se hayan
confirmado o se sospechan casos para
ayudar a mitigar el riesgo de un brote
grande o disruptivo de la enfermedad
el país había enfrentado entre 2010 y
2019 una enorme epidemia de cólera que
provocó la muerte de 10.000 personas el
origen de la epidemia se le atribuyó a
Los cascos azules quienes arrojaron
heces a un río la ONU reconoció su
responsabilidad en 2016